bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans
savouregarde au sommaire ce soir un
économiste qui décoiffe Timothée Paris
que votre livre ralentir ou périr
cartonne en librairie alors vous êtes
convaincus que la décroissance et la
seule réponse possible au dérèglement
climatique à la crise climatique vous
allez nous expliquer pourquoi dans la
seconde partie de l'émission dans notre
grand débat ce soir cette question et si
on passait tous à la semaine de quatre
jours l'essayer c'est l'adopter c'est en
tout cas ce que disent la plupart des
entreprises et des salariés qui l'ont
expérimenté jusqu'à présent mais peut-on
vraiment la généraliser cet utopie
peut-elle devenir réalité ce sera le
thème du débat avec nos invités on
terminera par le parti pris de nos
affranchis avec un nouveau venu ce soir
vous verrez je vous laisse la surprise
et puis la chronique Bourbon Express qui
sera consacrée à un rapport
parlementaire au goût amer pour le
rassemblement national voilà pour le
sommaire vous êtes prêts et là c'est
parti pour savoir
[Musique]
et si on passait tous à la semaine de
quatre jours alors l'idée a longtemps
été considéré au mieux comme farfelu au
pire comme totalement irréaliste mais
les temps changent semble-t-il et les
esprits évoluent il faut dire que le
covid est passé par là entre temps notre
rapport au travail à changer alors le
moment est-il enfin venu pour un
débattre avec nous ce soir j'accueille
Daniel Simonet bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes
député la France insoumise de Paris une
autre députée de Paris à nos côtés ce
soir Fanta Beretta bonsoir député
Renaissance vous avez travaillé dans le
domaine des ressources humaines avant
avant cette vie de député si on peut
dire également à nos côtés pierre
larouture ou député européen du parti
nouvelle donne alors vous c'est un
combat la semaine de quatre jours que
vous portez depuis plus de 30 ans je
crois 30 ans pile tant pis on fête
l'anniversaire actuellement Jean-Yves
Boulin alors vous êtes sociologue
chercheur associé à l'iriso à Paris
Dauphine et vous menez actuellement une
enquête je crois auprès d'entreprise et
de salariés qui expérimentent la semaine
de quatre jours c'est bien cela oui
enfin notre grand témoin je ne le
présent plus Timothée Paris sentez-vous
libre évidemment d'intervenir à
n'importe quel moment dans notre débat
mais pour commencer on accueille
Stéphane blackovski qui va nous aider à
mieux cerner les enjeux de ce débat sur
la semaine de 4 jours
bonsoir Clément bonsoir à toutes et tous
alors je ne sais pas si vous vous
souvenez mais début février Gabriel
Attal avait tenté d'allumer un
contre-feu dans l'opinion alors qu'on
était en plein milieu du conflit d'air
trade donc je vous laisse le rappel
l'article l'idée c'est que puisqu'on va
devoir travailler 2 ans de plus et ben
peut-être que on pourrait offrir de
nouvelles qualités de confort au travail
en passant la semaine de 4 jours alors
attention c'était bien sûr une
expérimentation donc ça a notamment été
testé à l'URSSAF de Picardie bon voilà
le résultat sur les 200 personnes à qui
on a proposé donc de condenser leur
temps de travail 36 heures en quatre
jours il y en a que 3 qui ont accepté de
travailler 9 heures par jour donc on
appelle ça un flop mais c'est à peu près
ça donc évidemment on pourrait on
importe tard en France peut-être mais en
Europe ça se développe cette réflexion
sur lesquelles je joue alors il y a
plein de cas différents en fait en
Belgique par exemple la loi a été votée
maintenant n'importe quel salarié peut
travailler 4 jours par semaine demandez
ça mais sans réduction du temps de
travail comme ce que propos Gabriel
Attal en Angleterre c'est pareil
réduction sur 4 jours condensation
pardon sur 4 jours sans réduction du
temps de travail donc là c'est une
expérimentation 60 entreprises ont testé
ça et apparemment 90% veulent continuer
alors semaine de 4 jours aussi en
Espagne mais attention là c'est
différent là parce que il y a réduction
du temps de travail donc en 4 jours mais
on passe de 40 à 32 heures à Salé régale
donc il y a 200 entreprises qui
participent à l'expérience mais elles
sont soutenues par le gouvernement qui
peut les aider financièrement l'idée
c'est on va voir ça pendant trois ans
quel effet ça peut avoir sur la
productivité bon on peut quand même
revenir en France parler un peu de nos
cas ou européen à l'emploi je l'oubliais
bon c'est pour vous dire que vraiment ça
marque l'idée que en Europe ça se
développe à la Commission de forcer
personne mais elle pense que vraiment
c'est là que et l'avenir et donc
revenons en France puisque c'était ma
préoccupation avec quelques cas où ça a
été testé ou ça marche plutôt bien de
son réfléchit sur ce dossier on lit un
article il y a forcément l'entreprise
lyonnaise LDLC qui appara grosse reprise
lyonnaises qui vont du matériel
informatique le patron voyez lui il est
très content mais là il est passé la
semaine de 4 jours avec réduction du
temps de travail à 32 heures et ça les
régal et pourtant ce qu'on entreprises
continue de faire de bons résultats
c'est vrai que c'est une question qu'on
se pose comment un patron accepterait de
garder le même salaire pour travailler
moins quels sont les avantages alors il
y a une société qui s'appelle Helmy qui
vendent l'énergie verte et qui a fait
une enquête qui chiffre un peu les
réactions sont ses salariés qui sont
passés donc à la semaine de 39 heures
sur 4 jours bon un absence moins de
démission donc ça c'est le patron est
content meilleur images de l'entreprise
ils étaient 23% à la recommandé
maintenant ils sont 48% donc comme année
dans une période on a du mal à recruter
notamment dans certains secteurs ben
voilà le passage à la semaine de quatre
jours ça peut être un manière d'attirer
de recruter des éléments de talents donc
finalement quand on cite des bons
exemples on se dit alors c'est
formidable la semaine de 4 jours on a
qu'à la généraliser donc on pose la
question au patron des patrons Geoffre
des yeux donc déjà qu'il avait du mal à
digérer les 35 heures donc la semaine de
4 jours moyen quoi
la semaine de 4 jours je pense que c'est
une une illusion
malheureusement c'est le temps dit rien
n'empêche une entreprise aujourd'hui de
faire la semaine de 4 jours donc il y a
pas de négociation à mettre la loi
n'interdit pas s'il y a un accord de le
faire alors attention on est parti pour
le débat pour ou contre la semaine des
quatre jours je vais vous laisser
débattre juste avant on laisse parler
Laurent Berger
je crois que ce serait un une erreur
d'en faire un débat un peu idéologique
comme on sait bien le faire dans notre
pays c'est à dire pour ou contre la
semaine des quatre jours ça peut être
très intéressant dans certaines
entreprises il faut le pousser il faut
le négocier dans d'autres ce sera
d'autres systèmes d'organisation du
travail qu'il faudra mettre en place bon
ben voilà Laurent Berger souhaite que le
débat soit pas trop réducteur sur la fin
de 4 jours mais on est sur LCP ce qu'on
a déjà vu des débats réducteurs sur LPS
merci beaucoup à vous Stéphane
blackovski on l'a bien compris avec
cette chronique de Stéphane toutes les
semaines de quatre jours ne se
ressemblent pas alors de quoi est-ce
qu'on parle exactement on va faire un
petit tour de table on commence par vous
pierre la roue tour où est elle
ressemble à quoi la semaine de 4 jours
que vous défendez depuis 30 ans
maintenant c'est la vraie semaine de
quatre jours il y en a qu'une pour vous
non mais il y en a plein non non au
contraire on voit que si c'est 4 jours
36 heures ça fait un bide on voit que
quand on propose dans l'URSSAF de
Picardie aux gens d'aller vers 4 jours
mais 36 heures il y en a trois ou quatre
Candy oui parce qu'ils n'ont pas envie
d'augmenter la durée quotidienne par
contre on voit que en Angleterre en
Espagne en Allemagne
IgA qui veulent c'est les 32 heures sans
base de salaire c'est-à-dire le
commissaire européen Nicolas Schmitt il
parle les quatre jours 32 heures il
s'agit pas d'en faire une règle
européenne mais dit si on veut faciliter
les recrutements si on veut créer des
emplois si on veut un meilleur équilibre
de vie un meilleur équilibre entre les
hommes et les femmes il faut aller vers
les quatre jours 32 heures et souvent on
dit que c'est moi qui a lancé le débat
en France il y a 30 ans en fait juste
avant nous il y avait Antoine Ribaux
celui qui a vraiment lancé le départ le
patron de Danone c'était à sur cinq
colonnes dans le journal Le Monde un des
plus grands patrons un vrai mec
dynamique qui avait créé une entreprise
maléfique et qui dit il faut passer à 32
heures sans étape intermédiaire ça
obligera tous les entreprises à créer
des emplois et c'est possible il y a
déjà 400 entreprises en France qui l'ont
mis en place si vous mangez un yaourt
Mamie Nova tous les salariés de Mamie
Nova sont passés à 4 jours 32 heures
sans baise de salaire et l'idée que
c'est et à créer ils ont créé 125
emplois et l'idée qu'on avait mis sur la
table avec Antoine Riboud avec Michel
Rocard c'est une idée très simple si
l'entreprise passe à 4 jours 32 heures
et qu'elle crée vraiment des emplois
elle arrête de payer les cotisations
chômage c'est comme ça que Mamie Nova
fleurie Michon ou plein d'autres on
passait ça permet de maintenir la
productivités
n'a pas augmenté on avait deux
contraintes ne pas baisser des salaires
pour ceux et celles qui sont là et ne
pas augmenter la masse salariale sinon
vous allez plus acheter des yaourts mi
Nova vous prendrez le concurrent et donc
l'idée c'est la CFDT qui avait donné
cette idée on peut utiliser autrement on
met des dizaines de milliards pour gérer
les conséquences du chômage on peut
utiliser une partie de cet argent pour
dire si vous créez des emplois on vous
met cet argent sur la table Jean-Yves
Boulin dans dans la recherche que vous
êtes en train de mener quel est le
modèle de semaine de 4 jours qui
prédomine dans les entreprises qui ont
fait ce choix est-ce que c'est réduction
du temps de travail et maintient du
salaire ou est-ce que c'est maintien du
temps de travail existant en France ou à
l'international je sais pas
décrivez-nous ce que vous avez vu non
alors tout à l'heure on a dit que au
Royaume-Uni c'était avec maintien de la
même durée en fait non sur les 60
entreprises qui ont été enquêtées
c'était vraiment le principe 180 sens
des on maintient la production à 100% on
baisse la durée du travail de 20%. donc
c'est-à-dire les 80% et on maintient le
salaire à 100%. alors en France
la situation est assez assez
différenciée quoi il y a des entreprises
qui effectivement
la semaine de quatre jours ça a existait
ça existe depuis assez longtemps en fait
ça existait avec Robien effectivement
avec ça a été un catalyseur la loi
revient entre autres de avec des accords
défensifs offensifs aujourd'hui on a des
entreprises qui sont à l'arrière il y a
un effet de mode un peu qui joue mais
dans les entreprises qui passent
beaucoup sont sur le modèle 32 heures
c'est-à-dire de passer de 35 à 32 parce
que c'est le plus le plus attractif pour
les salariés mais avec le cas le cas
d'URSSAF mais il y a des grandes
entreprises qui ont dit écoutez si vous
voulez travailler 4 jours Accenture par
exemple mais avec la même durée du
travail et du côté du patronat on vient
de l'entendre c'est un patronat très
innovant on le voit et du côté du
gouvernement actuellement aujourd'hui
c'est vraiment non quoi c'est à dire on
va voir avec vous justement quand tu as
parlé d'une utopie etc voilà c'est pas
une utopie parce que c'est quelque chose
qui déroule aujourd'hui alors en tous
les cas dans les entreprises en fait on
a eu on a eu 200 cloches du côté du
gouvernement il les avait de borne il y
a un an qui était vraiment pas favorable
à l'idée en tout cas de généraliser
cette mesure et qui disait que de toute
façon ça poserait des problèmes de
pouvoir d'achat et puis Gabriel Attal
qui s'est montré plus ouvert plus
récemment comme l'expliquait Stéphane
blackovski il augmente la durée du
travail alors Fanta béreté la maintient
et il a même à 36 heures donc c'est des
9h quoi vous députés de la majorité vous
y croyez la semaine de quatre jours avec
réduction du temps de travail ça vous
paraît possible réalisable souhaitable
écoutez je pense que on est dans un
moment où on se pose beaucoup de
questions sur sur le travail on sort pas
tout à fait en plus du texte retraite
donc il y a je pense tout un tas de
sujets sur lesquels il va falloir il va
falloir discuter attendre un résultat
d'enquête etc moi personnellement parce
que je suis plutôt là à titre finalement
personnel aujourd'hui
l'idée c'est plutôt de proposer
sur la base du volontariat c'est à dire
que l'imposer en fait au sein de
l'ensemble de nos entreprises moi je n'y
crois pas parce qu'en fait il y a des
différences on l'a vu notamment avec le
télétravail tous les postes n'étaient
pas télétravables et je pense que toutes
les activités ne peuvent pas s'organiser
peut-être sur cette semaine là mais en
tout cas aussi rapidement donc liberté
de choix aux entreprises pas de
négociation en accord de branche pas de
loi voté à l'Assemblée sur ce sujet une
période où les Français nous disent
aussi j'ai envie de travailler j'ai
envie d'un peu plus de liberté j'ai
envie de pouvoir m'organiser autrement
et je pense que les Juifs trop tôt c'est
peut-être pas ce qu'il faut mais par
contre mener des expérimentations donc
au sein de secteur au sein d'entreprise
comme l'a fait Gabriel Attal je pense
que c'est peut-être le bon moyen de
commencer Daniel Simonet alors vous vous
êtes pour la semaine de quatre jours ou
32 heures si j'ai bien compris mais en
fait la réduction du temps de travail
c'est un progrès social
et la réduction de temps de travail à la
fois sur la vie sur l'année sur la
semaine sur la journée c'est important
donc aller vers une semaine de quatre
jours sans perdre de salaire et où on
fait 32 heures et pas 35 pour nous c'est
un vrai progrès social et ça aussi des
vertus pour le combat féministe et ça
répond aussi à des enjeux écologiques
d'ailleurs dans l'exemple de la
Grande-Bretagne que vous donnez qui est
sur sur une semaine de 4 jours on a vu
que ça a eu des résultats en termes de
en termes d'émancipation extrêmement
importante puisque vous faites baisser
aussi la souffrance au travail en fait
baisser l'absentéisme pour maladie vous
vous permettez finalement aux
travailleuses aux travailleurs de
regagner la maîtrise d'une partie de
leur temps c'est à dire la question du
temps libre et sur les conséquences
écologiques il y a une étude qui est
extrêmement intéressante de
l'Association britannique plateforme et
qui indique que le passage et une
semaine de quatre jours sans perdre de
salaire permettrait de diminuer
l'empreinte carbone du Royaume-Uni de
120 127 millions de tonnes par an d'ici
20 2025 ça veut dire une diminution de
21,3% vous y croyez vous Timothée Paris
économiste de l'écologie à un impact
positif de la semaine de 4 jours sur sur
l'environnement et même plus c'est à
dire que la réduction du temps de
travail si l'on doit s'engager dans une
transition donc de décroissance on va
voir la production se contracter et donc
c'est normal qu'on devrait voir une
réduction du temps de travail d'ailleurs
on pourrait faire le calcul inverse
c'est à dire qu'aujourd'hui on pourrait
calculer pour la France en partant d'une
certaine intensité carbone maximale
qu'on ne devrait pas dépasser se poser
la question combien d'heures
pouvons-nous nous nous permettre de
travailler sans dépasser le travail
deviendrait donc un luxe et si l'on fait
le calcul aujourd'hui dans les pays de
l'OCDE la moyenne la moyenne d'heures de
travail par semaine que l'on peut se
permettre de travailler c'est 5 heures à
partir de la sixième heure vous êtes
pour la journée de travail par semaine
la demi-journée tout dépend de
l'évolution de l'intensité on peut
regarder pour la Suède la Suède est à 12
heures mais c'est vrai qu'il y a une
véritable question d'empreinte
écologique et se dire sur le très long
terme de avoir cette grande discussion
sur la durée du temps de travail
toujours en connexion avec la question
des budgets écologiques limités bon
alors là on est resté un peu dans la
théorie en faisant ce petit tour de
table j'aimerais qu'on rentre dans le
concret avec un exemple d'entreprise qui
a fait ce choix de passer au 4 jours
qu'en pensent les salariés qu'elle
bénéfice les employeurs peuvent-ils en
tirer pierre Michael Carniel et Pierre
Beretta se sont rendus chez MJ
conditionnement dans l'Aisne donc c'est
une petite entreprise qui s'est lancée
au mois d'octobre dernier dans la
semaine de quatre jours sans réduction
du temps de travail
donc ici vous êtes dans le dépôt où on
stocke tous nos aérosols vides donc
c'est des boîtiers métalliques pour
répondre à un contexte d'inflation cette
société de conditionnement d'aérosol
après une décision radicale en novembre
2022 on s'est réuni que les salariés on
essayait de réfléchir une solution pour
pour faire des économies d'énergie au
niveau de l'entreprise et pour essayer
d'améliorer la qualité de vie et
redonner du pouvoir d'achat aux salariés
et finalement c'est la semaine de quatre
jours qui s'est qui s'est imposé comme
solution donc en fait on a on a décidé
de concentrer le temps de travail
hebdomadaire qui est de 37h30 dans
l'entreprise et donc on l'a on l'a
concentré sur quatre jours le 5 ce qui
nous a permis en fait de fermer le site
de production le vendredi résultat 5000
euros d'économie d'énergie qui ont
permis à l'entreprise de verser une
prime annuelle de 500 euros au 9
salariés de l'entreprise désormais ils
travaillent 9h par jour une charge pas
trop lourde pour eux bon je travaille
1h30 en plus par jour franchement quand
vous êtes au travail faire une heure une
heure et demie en plus ce premier champ
je me lève une fois de moins le matin
enfin la semaine
on fait des économies d'essence alors
j'ai eu au moins une journée de plus
pour me reposer pour m'occuper de chez
moi donc c'est qu'un avantage la semaine
de cinq jours un souvenir déjà lointain
revenir comme avant le travail dès le
vendredi
savoir que jeudi soir vous êtes vous
êtes en week-end c'est quand même pas
rien la nouvelle organisation du travail
fait consensus c'est les salariés
l'entreprise l'a donc pérennisé on s'est
laissé une période de trois mois pour
tester cette organisation au bout de
trois mois on a fait un petit bilan avec
les salariés 100% des salariés étaient
convaincus par la nouvelle organisation
et donc aujourd'hui on l'a inscrit
vraiment dans le fonctionnement de
l'entreprise donc c'est quelque chose
qui va perdurer normalement de
nombreuses années cette entreprise
pourrait faire école car aujourd'hui en
France seulement 1% des entreprises ont
adopté la semaine de travail de quatre
jours
Jean-Yves Boulin vous évoquiez tout à
l'heure l'exemple de l'URSSAF où ça n'a
pas marché ou très peu de salariés vous
voulez faire 9 heures par jour là c'est
un peu le contre-exemple tout le monde a
l'air content de travailler une heure
trente de plus par jour c'est pas
méchant bien salarié donc c'est aussi je
connais pas l'entreprise simplement je
voudrais savoir si c'est des hommes par
exemple qui travaillent dans cette
entreprise en majorité ce qui semble
être le cas on a deux hommes là qui
viennent essentiellement de s'exprimer
la question d'articulation vie au
travail via leur travail qui est un des
éléments qu'on met en avant pour pour
mettre en oeuvre la semaine de quatre
jours je vais dire du côté des femmes et
à l'URSSAF c'est bien c'est ça bien été
le problème c'est c'est non quoi ça
marche pas on ne peut pas aller chercher
les enfants à l'école on peut pas s'en
occuper le rentrer le soir
qui étaient données par les salariés qui
n'ont pas voulu faire ce choix voilà moi
je pense que la réflexion à avoir c'est
une réflexion sur le travail d'abord et
ça il faut avoir une réflexion sur le
travail et par exemple chez LDLC que on
a vu on a vu le rôle Laurent de la
Clergerie tout à l'heure
chez LDLC il avait pensé au départ j'ai
longuement discuté avec lui quand je
suis allé dans son entreprise il avait
pensé au départ assez à 35 heures en
fait son idée c'était donner un jour de
plus donc il était sur l'idée de 35
heures il a réfléchi il a dit chez moi
la moyenne d'âge c'est 37 ans ils ont
tous des jeunes enfants ça va pas
marcher ça va pas marcher il est passé à
32 heures il a proposé à 3h mais
derrière parce que moi je dirais je suis
un peu souvent l'image le rang de la
Clergerie c'est un peu le rebou du 21e
siècle 21ème siècle je dirais parce que
il a une vraie politique sociale
derrière c'est à dire qu'il a dit à ses
équipes réfléchissez au travail est-ce
comment il peut comment il peut comment
on peut faire est-ce que c'est faisable
est-ce que c'est faisable s'il y a des
recrutements vous me vous me le dites il
avait vraiment proposé il a été très
étonné parce que dans les entrepôts de
la logistique où les gens ils mettent
des paquets etc c'est il y a de la
fatigue physique etc il a peut-être très
étonné parce qu'il lui est pas remonté
de demande de recrutement il a pas
recruté en fait il a recruté un petit
peu dans les dans les boutiques parce
qu'il a les gens se sont réalisé en
binôme pour pouvoir assurer la
continuité il ferme pas l'entreprise il
ferme jamais l'entreprise l'entreprise
elle ferme six jours comme avant six
jours par semaine distribue du matériel
informatique il faut voir aussi que mdlc
c'est une entreprise qui a une explosion
de son chiffre d'affaires pendant le
pendant le confinement aussi hein sinon
sur un secteur porteur très porteur etc
et moi je suis c'est pour ça que je
regarde la différence avec les
expérimentations qui sont faites au
Royaume-Uni ou aux USA et cetera par ma
collègue Juliette Shore de Boston
College c'est que c'est ils suivent une
expérimentation sur 6 mois or c'est très
connu en sociologie sur six mois on
adopte des comportements vertueux là on
est sur des entreprises ça fait deux
déjà deux ans et j'ai regardé dans une
autre entreprise qui a dans la région
lyonnaise aussi qui fait de
l'infogérance et là aussi il ferme pas
du tout il reste sur 32 heures etc mais
effectivement il y a une réflexion sur
le travail sur l'organisation du travail
ce qu'il faut éviter de mettre
d'intensification du travail parce que
là c'est vraiment un des gros problèmes
qui a eu en particulier
si on a des journées trop chargées si on
demandait à l'arrière de faire la même
chose qui ont été menées montrent
effectivement qu'il y a une baisse du
burn out qui a une baisse de l'intensité
du travail donc ça veut dire que ça
s'accompagne de réorganisation du
travail qui permet justement d'éviter
ces effets dysfonctionnements c'est
c'est généralisable ce dispositif ça
peut s'appliquer à tous les secteurs
tous les métiers pas en trois semaines
ça c'est sûr mais si on prend le temps
de même que les congés payés au début on
pense que c'était de la folie même Léon
Blum ne croyez pas au congés payés ou la
semaine de 6 jours il y a beaucoup de
gens qui pensaient que c'était pas
possible et petit à petit en gros tout
le monde a des congés payés soit
peut-être les agriculteurs mais dans
tous les métiers on ça voilà donc après
ça quand Fanta demander à ce qu'il faut
faire une loi ou pas je pense que
personne ne veut une loi qui est rend
obligatoire les 32 heures par contre si
on veut éviter les burn out si on veut
qu'il y ait des créations en emploi
possibles on avait fait un livre pour
expliquer ça avec Michel Rocard et le
patron de Flammarion était complètement
convaincu il voulait passer de tout
Flammarion pendant deux heures il dit
c'est pas possible parce que tu vas
devoir créer des emplois et tu veux pas
baisser les salaires donc sans doute ce
qui est utile aujourd'hui je parle aux
député c'est la même chose que ce qu'on
avait obtenu en 96 c'est une loi qui ne
oblige rien mais qui donne un outil en
disant si vous la loi de Robien si vous
salarié et patron vous voulez passer à
32 heures et vraiment 32 heures non pas
des journées plus longues mais 32 heures
avec des créations d'emploi il reste
quand même plus de 4 millions d'inscrits
à Pôle Emploi donc c'est quand même bien
si on crée aussi quelques emplois et
bien on vous met sur la table une
exonération qui correspond au fait qu'il
y aura moins de chômeurs à payer je vois
sourire une loi qui offre un cadre sans
imposer les choses c'est le problème
c'est c'est toujours de d'aborder la
question par les exonérations de
cotisations patronales moi j'estime que
s'il y a 10% de création d'emplois en
CDI parce qu'on proposait depuis le
début c'est des contreparties aux
exonérations tout le monde est créé 10%
d'emploi en CDI elle peut arrêter de
payer les cotisations chômage et cette
équilibré pour tout le monde je vais là
la démonstration de Patrick Artus qui
dit que celui-ci MBT équilibré pas tu
auras effectivement moins de chôme à
payer et plus de gens qui vont cotiser
pour les caisses de retraite ou les
caisses de maladies quand mamie Nova
crée 125 emplois ses 125 personnes qui
retrouvent un salaire qui ont une vie
normale qui vont payer la TVA et qui
vont cotiser pour les caisses de
retraite en fait la question de son
c'est il faut à la fois réduire le temps
de travail pour pouvoir libérer du temps
permet à chacune et chacun aussi de se
construire soi-même dans un temps où
c'est la personne elle-même qui
choisisse qu'elle en fait donc ça c'est
d'abord une orientation de société
deuxièmement il faut aussi répartir les
richesses parce que c'est quand même
inouï vous avez
dans la répartition de la richesse
produite bien le capital on a pris plus
10 points sur sur ces 20 dernières
années donc il faut répartir la richesse
et n'est pas acceptable qu'à chaque fois
qu'on parle réduction du temps de
travail on se dise ah bah il faudrait
aussi réduire les salaires non il faut
mieux répartir parce qu'aujourd'hui on
évolue de cela et ensuite comprendre que
repenser le travail c'est aussi se dire
mais en fait à besoin on doit satisfaire
et repenser l'utilité du travail et là
ça rejoindra ce qu'on disait sur le fait
qu'une baisse du temps de travail peut
permettre aussi de réduire notre
empreinte si tenter qu'on pense aussi
quel est le travail qui est utile nous
on pense qu'il y a une bifurcation
écologique à engager pour que on se dise
notre impératif c'est de répondre à
satisfaire les besoins sociaux et
apprendre en compte les enjeux et les
urgences climatiques et que nos
ressources sont finies donc c'est pas
travailler plus pour produire tout et
n'importe quoi d'ailleurs prenez
l'exemple on peut tout à fait mesurer
que la banalisation du travail du
dimanche et bien à graver un impact
écologique une empreinte écologique
complètement aberrante pour par ailleurs
plus d'aliénation parce que même les
gens qui ne travaillent pas le dimanche
se disent maintenant que les magasins
sont ouverts on peut y aller bon bah
c'est pas vraiment un temps libéré et
sur l'égalité femme homme ça a été par
ailleurs aussi une grosse régression
parce que c'est généralement les femmes
qui travaillent le dimanche sans pour
autant qu'on les libère des tâches des
tâches ménagères vraiment je pense qu'il
faut se rappeler que les 35 heures ont
permis par ailleurs de créer plus de 350
000 emplois que oui un moment donné il
faut quand même de la contrainte voilà
que là on peut on doit pouvoir se fixer
un objectif déjà de restaurer les 35
heures parce qu'en moyenne on travaille
plutôt 307 heures que 35 heures en ce
moment en France pour les il faut donc
tendre vers la semaine deux quatre jours
sans perdre de salaire mais en
travaillant 32 heures pour du temps
libéré sans t'avoir été cette réduction
du temps de travail que défaire Daniel
Simonet c'est pas un objectif politique
pour vous aujourd'hui
je pense que pour nous et les Français
nous bien souvent répété c'est quel sens
au travail c'est pour moi la vraie
question du moment est-ce que ça peut
pas redonner du sens au travail je pense
que ça fait partie d'un ensemble en fait
ça peut pas être la réponse là immédiate
en tout cas pour les mois à venir parce
que de toute manière moi je ne pense pas
qu'on puisse le faire de partout pour
toutes les activités mais par contre ce
que disent les gens c'est moi je suis
malheureux il y a beaucoup de gens qui
nous ont dit ça je suis malheureux dans
mon travail dans l'émission qui me sont
confiées donc je pense que moi pour moi
la priorité elle est là comment on fait
pour que les gens n'aient pas la boule
au ventre le dimanche en se disant
demain matin je vais aller travailler et
c'est en s'asseyant aussi tous autour de
la table et avec les travaux qui sont
menés par les uns et les autres qu'on
peut essayer de proposer quelque chose
on arrive à un croisement donc qui est
assez assez difficile et il y a une
réflexion globale qui doit être menée
parce que moi quand je pense à réduction
de centrage je pense aussi par exemple
aux gens et j'aurais peut-être la
réponse ici qui sont forfait jour tout
simplement donc comment on réorganise
c'est des gens qui travaillent pas
forcément donc 35 heures par semaine
nous le savons tous ici qui travaillent
bien plus on comment on fait ça ensuite
des grands intérêts de la semaine de
quatre jours c'est que ça parle à tout
le monde que vous soyez Cais que vous
soyez ouvriers commercial ingénieur
directeur financier on voit bien dans
une entreprise que ça motive les gens y
compris pour régler les problèmes
d'organisation parce que tout le monde
va en profiter tout le monde sait ce que
ça veut dire il y a un jour par semaine
où je vais pas au boulot et un jour par
semaine où je peux faire la grasse mat
un jour par semaine ou je vais pas mon
costume mon bleu de travail où j'ai que
je ne suis pas dans les transports en
commun ou dans les bouchons et ça ça
parle à tout le monde moi j'ai l'autre
jour j'ai fait un tweet qui a fait 3
millions de vues j'ai été étonné par le
nombre et par la diversité des gens qui
mettaient des commentaires c'était des
jeunes et des vieux c'était des gens
très qualifiés et puis des moins
qualifiés c'était des gens des grandes
villes et des gens des milieux ruraux
tout le monde pour des raisons
différentes il y en a qui ont des
enfants en bas âge il y en a qui ont mis
du temps pour se former il y en a qui
ont leur maman qui est à l'hôpital ils
veulent du temps il y en a qui veulent
ils en ont marre du boulot ils veulent
réorienter leur vie il y en a qui
veulent s'occuper de la vie associative
il y a des motivations très très
différentes et c'est l'intérêt des
quatre jours c'est que ça peut quand
même créer et une dynamique dans
l'entreprise ce que j'ai pas dit aussi
c'est que ça permet d'enrichir le
travail par Monsieur Mamie Nova il y a
ils ont fait un plan de coin
investissement formation et un jour par
semaine ou le chef n'est pas là le chef
ça peut être le contremaître le
directeur de l'usine ou la directrice
voilà et si le client appelle on va pas
dire attendez revenir dans trois jours
parce que le chef étant RTT donc on a
amélioré on a enrichi le travail des
ouvriers donc les ouvriers et ouvrières
travaillent moins longtemps mais leur
travail est souvent plus riche c'est
aussi pour ça que l'absentéisme recule
alors l'absenté il se recule l'image de
l'entreprise s'améliore il y a une vraie
activité quel est l'impact sur la
productivité est-ce qu'il y a des études
sérieuses qui ont été menées là-dessus
alors les pour l'instant les rapports
qui ont été faits sur les
expérimentations et les deux entreprises
que j'ai que j'ai observé convergent de
ce point de vue là c'est à dire qu'il y
a une c'est d'ailleurs un peu le
problème par rapport à la question du
partage du travail dont on parlait
avec les lois européens ou les lois les
lois oui c'est à dire que effectivement
il y a des gains de productivité qui
sont tout à fait considérables ce qui
fait que ce qui a amené d'ailleurs on
voit bien chez LDLC il a pas embauché
donc c'est à cause des gains de
productivité alors comment se produit
ces gains de produits c'est ça vous êtes
intéressante
les gens effectivement se sentent plus
reposés etc dans les dans les entrepôts
je les ai pas encore interrogé les gens
des entrepôts je vais y aller bientôt
dans deux semaines mais il y a quand
même cette bon voilà il semble qu'il y
ait une énergie ils sont moins fatigués
surtout que la comment comment est
organisé le jour off il y a des gens qui
choisissent par exemple de couper la
semaine avec le jour off c'est pas
toujours le vendredi ou le lundi par
exemple pour faire des week-ends la
fameuse société de la flemme etc c'est
pas du tout ça les gens ils
réfléchissent tout à fait à la façon
dont ils veulent passer leur jour de
leurs jours off et donc effectivement
les gains de productivité ils peuvent
être aussi obtenus par une
intensification du travail là c'est
autre chose c'est-à-dire la base du coup
quel est votre regard à vous baisse des
pauses la réduction de la de la pose des
journées par exemple quel est votre
sur
ces chiffres c'est cette analyse là
en tant que économiste écologique moi je
fais très attention dès qu'on parle de
gains de productivité aussi de comparer
avec deux autres familles de gains les
gains de convivialité par exemple au
sens du travail donc à la qualité à
l'organisation du travail et bien sûr
les gains de soutenabilité ce quand on
parle de productivité on ne regarde
qu'une chose on regarde les choses qui
sont produites et surtout les choses qui
sont produites que l'on peut vendre donc
dans cette économie monétaire que l'on
mesure avec le PIB qui ne prend pas en
compte la diversité de toutes les choses
par exemple que l'on fait quand on n'est
pas au travail donc une baisse de la
productivité si ça se solde par exemple
si on parle agriculture on sort d'un
modèle d'agriculture industrielle et on
va perdre en productivité horaire mais
on va gagner en convivialité en
soutenabilité parce qu'on va passer vers
un modèle agroécologique permaculturel
ou là qui aura un moindre impact sur les
écosystèmes on peut voir ça comme un
progrès même si la productivité horaire
baisse et d'ailleurs aujourd'hui si on
veut sortir des énergies fossiles et
avoir des modes ce qu'on appelle les low
tech on va voir la productivité horaire
baisser et derrière il y a une véritable
question c’est-à-dire que si on revient
dans les années 60 qui était les années
60 c'était le dernier moment où
l'empreinte écologique de la France
était un peu près égale à sa biocapacité
depuis on est en déficit depuis les
depuis 1960 la productive horaire
macroéconomique a été multiplié par 2,7
on a choisi de traduire ces gains de
productivité par plus de production si
on avait choisi au lieu de plus produire
de maintenir la production mais de
traduire ses gains de productivité par
une réduction de temps de travail
aujourd'hui on serait à la semaine de 16
heures
donc là aussi derrière cette question du
travail il y a une véritable question de
quoi avons-nous vraiment besoin est-ce
qu'il y a pas certaines formes de
travail qu'on peut tout simplement
simplifier et juste dire que la
production à tout prix ne répond pas
forcément à des besoins à vos yeux c'est
ça l'idée c'est
l'économie de telle qu'elle est
aujourd'hui a perdu de vue les besoins
la question des besoins complètement
surtout quand on vient définir le
travail dans une catégorie assez
abstraite de l'emploi salarié tout
emploi salarié ne se vaut pas et le
travail n'existe pas juste pour que des
personnes puissent avoir un revenu et un
pouvoir d'achat le travail c'est
l'activité humaine donc là il va falloir
l'ouvrir et insérer cette activité
humaine dans l'activité des écosystèmes
car le retour rouge juste sur on parlait
souvent de la fracture qui existe entre
ceux qui peuvent télétravailler ceux qui
peuvent pas est-ce que la semaine de
quatre jours peut aussi être une réponse
pour résorber un peu cette fracture
parce que elle peut s'appliquer par
exemple aux ouvriers au personnels
soignants à tous ces métiers qui
impliquent d'être présent la réponse est
oui et je je crois qu'elle s'applique
déjà quand je dis avec la loi de Robien
on a 400 entreprises on a de toutes les
tailles de tous les métiers je vais
parler des grandes entreprises comme
Fleury Michon ou Mamie Nova mais si vous
allez dans mon coin des Pyrénées vous
achetez une chocolatine ceux qui font le
contrôle bactériologique c'est une PME
qui est aussi passée à 4 jours ce qui
font l'insémination porcine pour les
gens de Bayonne c'est moins
d'appétissant mais ça aussi passe à 4
jours à Bordeaux si une entreprise de
charpente métallique dans les Alpes et
l'entreprise de logiciels ailleurs c'est
une agence de publicité au début c'était
un peu compliqué parce que c'était un
peu le bazar pendant trois mois et puis
ils ont posé des règles en disant le
mardi et le jeudi tout le monde doit
être là on fait des réunions plus
efficaces on garde de la convivialité
mais on fait des réunions moins longues
on arrive à l'heure voilà donc on voit
comment beaucoup on a des entreprises
dans tous les secteurs d'activité dans
un cabinet d'avocat enfin j'ai tous les
toutes les tailles et donc je crois que
c'est possible ça n'est pas possible on
claquant dans les doigts parfois aussi
on fait des groupes en employeur dans
mon coin des Pyrénées il y a deux
entreprises il y avait des saisonnalités
différentes au lieu d'avoir des petits
boulots pendant trois mois on s'est dit
on se met ensemble et on fait des CDI
pour que les gens aient un vrai boulot
ils vont travailler plus ici pendant 6
mois et ben donc tu es tout à fait
possible la question internationale
relance les 35 heures avait tué le débat
parlons clairement en même temps les 35
heures avec 350 000 emplois mais c'était
un vrai bazar pour être poli les 35
heures à l'hôpital parce que le
ministère n'avait pas voulu ouvrir les
écoles d'infirmière donc c'est ce qui
était scandaleux donc les 35 heures ont
tué le débat et maintenant on voit
comment le débat revient dans tous les
pays d'Europe donc il faut qu'on ait un
vrai débat et je continue à penser
puisqu'on a deux députés national ici
qu'une loi qui permet aux entreprises de
le faire dans de bonnes conditions avec
une exonération on a tous les calculs
pour dire que c'est efficace pour les
finances publiques ce serait tout à fait
utile de donner cet outil pour la
négociation Daniel Simonet moi je pense
que il faut aussi vraiment se
réapproprier ce débat sur ce que nous
faisons du temps libre on a essayé de le
porter dans la bataille contre la
retraite à 64 ans parce que nous faire
travailler deux ans de plus et nous
faire perdre les deux meilleures années
de retraite où on est en bonne santé ça
a un impact sur le temps libre ça veut
dire plein de élus locaux en moins de
mère en moins parce que c'est souvent un
moment donné dans plein de petits
villages des retraités qui sur leur
temps libre du coup se réalise autrement
dans l'intérêt général c'est aussi
beaucoup de militants associatifs
bénévoles en moins c'est aussi tout le
travail qu'on fait de s'occuper des
enfants ou de s'occuper de ses aînés et
ça
ça tout le débat sur la productivité
évidemment parce que ça n'est pas du
temps exploitée par le logique
capitaliste or c'est du temps librement
choisi très utile en termes de
d'émancipation collective
et la mise en perspective avec la
réforme des retraites
simplement il y a tout un tout une
discussion au travers de l'IA de
l'impact sur nos métiers et sur le fait
que sur certains métiers en fait lia va
libérer en fait du temps et là où je
pense que nous devons discuter aussi là
bien entendu avec les branches c'est ce
temps libéré en fait sur certaines
tâches qu'est-ce qu'on en fait donc oui
effectivement il y a des réflexions je
pense que nous devons mener sur comment
ne pas rajouter dessus faire en sorte de
garder les gens en entreprise pour faire
quoi donc voilà c'est toutes ces
questions là je pense que ça dépasse un
petit peu la semaine de la semaine de
quatre jours je pense qu'il y a vraiment
une réflexion à mener et ce que je
disais sur le rapport au travail très
bien en prenant en compte ce que
Timothée disait tout à l'heure bien
entendu merci beaucoup c'est terminé je
suis désolé pour ceux qui veulent qu'il
y ait une loi qui leur permet de passer
à 32 heures vous allez sur le site
semaine de 4 jours.fr
un petit coup de pubs les missions
étaient intéressantes mais elle répond
pas tout semaine de 4 jours.fr y compris
pour demander au députés qui a une loi
qui permet de passer à 32 heures sans
base de salaire le message est passé
merci à vous à vous quatre d'être venu
débattre sur ce plateau dans quelques
instants ce sera au tour de nos
affranchis ce soir on est très heureux
d'accueillir un nouveau monde dans
l'équipe Nathan de verre écrivain
philosophe qui se penchera ce soir sur
le concept de guerre étendu que qui est
proposé par la revue le grand continent
concept pour mieux comprendre le monde
d'aujourd'hui le mot de la semaine
Mariette d'arrêt grand darrigan a choisi
de nous parler d'un mot dont le
gouvernement s'est saisi en début de
semaine le mot fraude enfin la chronique
Bourbon express de Marco polmier nous
racontera la douche froide prise par le
RN hier à l'Assemblée une histoire
d'arroseur arrosé vous verrez
allez on va passer à notre grand témoin
à présent être Timothée Paris vous êtes
donc économiste plus précisément
chercheur en économie écologique lauréat
du Prix écolo Hobbs pour ce livre
ralentir ou périr qui est présent ici
vous y dessinez des contours d'une
société décroissante et même post
croissance vous allez nous expliquer
tout cela mais d'abord qui êtes-vous et
que proposez-vous exactement votre
portrait signé Hélène Bonduelle
si on vous invite Timothée Paris c'est
parce que vous nous demandez de choisir
entre ralentir ou périr rien de moins
entre une décroissance choisie
aujourd'hui ou un effondrement subi
demain et visiblement le sujet passionne
tout est parti de votre thèse sur la
décroissance publie il y a quatre ans et
dont les téléchargements ont subitement
explosé en 2021 plus de 40 000 43 000
aujourd'hui
Timothée Paris 43 ans vous êtes
chercheur en économie écologique qu'à
l'université de lune en Suède et vous
venez de remporter le Prix écolo Hobbs
pour votre ouvrage ralentir ou périr
issue de votre thèse déjà vendu à plus
de 30 000 exemplaires la décroissance
c'est un choix politique il va falloir
faire une sélection dans tout ce que
l'économie produit par secteur pas bien
et servir par classe de consommateurs et
se dire bah ça on va produire moins ça
on va produire plus et vous parcourez
les amphis des chantres de la croissance
pour défendre votre idée les grandes
entreprises les écoles d'ingénieurs et
de commerce vous êtes là où on ne vous
attend pas et vous enjouez quand je vous
vois ici moi ça me rappelle la première
fois que j'entendais de parler de
décroissance c'était dans un amphi et je
me souviens avoir été ici dans la salle
et en fait
nous nous sommes moqués de cette
personne qui était venue parler de
décroissance et je me souviens donc de
la de l'arrogance d'un deuxième année
d'économie donc avoir pensé mais qui
sait se plouc ce guignol mes injectés
dans les veines des politiques la
décroissance n'est pas si simple Bruno
Le Maire la fustige le dernier rapport
Pisani ferry n'y crois pas ce n'est pas
par la décroissance qu'on atteindra la
neutralité climatique pas plus
qu'Emmanuel Macron si nous produisons
moins nous travaillons moins nous ne
pourrons plus financer le modèle social
qui est le nôtre un modèle de
décroissance c'est un modèle de
décroissance aussi de notre modèle
social
finalement c'est une révolution
économique sociale et démocratique que
vous prenez mais alors Timothée parric
nous avons une question comment
convaincre renoncement comment
convaincre l'opinion publique que moins
c'est mieux
alors je reprends la question Timothée
qu'on a tous en tête la formule employée
par Emmanuel Macron quand il a voulu un
peu se moquer des décroissants où il
comparaissait au modèle Amish au retour
à la lampe à huile comment convaincre
que moins c'est mieux et déjà il faut
recentrer le débat sur la question du
plus quand on parle de croissance
économique c'est pas plus de bien-être
c'est pas plus de qualité de vie de
temps libre ou de choses comme ça on l'a
bien vu c'est plus de PIB de produits
quand on regarde et qu'on décortique un
petit peu comment le PIB est calculé on
se rend compte c'est un indicateur qui
est complètement aveugle non seulement
l'état de la nature ça c'est un problème
mais aussi à l'objectif final d'une
économie qui est de satisfaire des
besoins de contenter d'augmenter la
qualité de vie donc qu'on arrive à faire
baisser le PIB c'est à dire cette espèce
d'agitation monétaire si justement ça va
libérer du temps libre pour qu'on puisse
faire des activités qui elles vont
augmenter la qualité de vie si surtout
ça nous permet de revenir dans les clous
des limites planétaires et donc d'éviter
les canicules les crises de l'eau et
tout ce qui va avec l'effondrement
climatique il faut voir ça comme un
enrichissement donc en fait il faut
déconstruire le mythe de la croissance
selon vous mais ce mythe en fait on est
biberonné au PIB depuis tout petit à
l'école dans les médias dans les
discours politiques tout le monde
associe la croissance au progrès au
progrès économique progrès social aussi
réduction des inégalités donc comment
s'attaquer à ça parce qu'il faut changer
de paradigme changer de mentalité
totalement alors moi en tant que
économiste j'essaye d'être assez
pédagogue quand je débat avec des
économistes par exemple leur donne le
défi écouté on va débattre de ce sujet
mais on n'a pas le droit d'utiliser le
terme croissance économique PIB revenu
national et là on voit tout de suite
qu'on a un petit peu embêté parce qu'on
a cette espèce de prêt à penser
croissance prospérité bien-être et on
amalgame tout cela alors qu'en fait non
on a des activités qui peuvent être en
croissance dans un PIB lui-même
croissant alors que on a une espérance
de vie qui peut baisser on a un taux de
pauvreté qui peut augmenter et on a
surtout une santé des écosystèmes qui en
chute libre complète donc là aujourd'hui
on a besoin d'un meilleur indicateur il
faut pas oublier le PIB il est né en
1930 c'était il y a 100 ans donc
aujourd'hui on a besoin d'un tableau de
bord beaucoup plus sophistiqué et on a
besoin surtout de se poser des questions
fondamentales sur et je sais que c'est
c'est vraiment ontologique presque mais
à quoi ça sert d'avoir une économie
et sortir un petit peu des catégories de
l'économie doit maximiser le PIB les
entreprises maximiser les profits nous
devons maximiser notre pouvoir d'achat
nous devons maintenir l'emploi et
l'inflation ces grandes catégories
derrière et se poser des vraies
questions d'écologie politique autour
des besoins et de la manière de les
satisfaire alors il y a aussi le mot de
décroissance est encore tabou dans la
bouche de la plupart de nos dirigeants
celui de sobriété commence à se faire
une place sauf que pour vous la sobriété
n'a aucun sens si on renonce pas à la
croissance vous parle même de fake news
exactement faire une stratégie de
sobriété c'est à dire essayer de
consommer moins mais tout en incitant à
produire plus c'est un petit peu freiné
et accéléré en même temps si on veut
justement aujourd'hui faire baisser
l'empreinte écologique totale parce que
c'est ça l'objectif on le connaît bien
pour les émissions de gaz à effet de
serre ce qu'on connaît moins c'est qu'il
faut faire baisser énormément d'autres
pression sur l'environnement il y a
l'eau il y a la biodiversité liée à
l'artificialisation des sols liés à
l'empreinte tous les matériaux et les
métaux et la biomasse que notre économie
utilise ça se résume pas à réduire nos
émissions de CO2 quoi non on a besoin de
faire un grand régime et moi j'ai
beaucoup étudié vraiment ce qui se passe
dans ces dans ces pays qui ont essayé
qui ont tout essayé de faire baisser
l'empreinte écologique totale et nous
n'arrivons pas à la baisser tout en
produisant en plus et même tout en
maintenant les niveaux de production
qu'on a aujourd'hui le seul moyen
vraiment de faire baisser l'empreinte
écologique totale encore si c'est notre
objectif c'est d'avoir à la fois une
sobriété de consommation donc consommer
moins mais que cette sobriété de
consommation elle soit connectée à un
renoncement de production donc c'est
simple par exemple on décide de moins
prendre l'avion au niveau de la
consommation et au lieu d'avoir des
compagnies aériennes qui vont faire des
soldes ou essayer de faire et là on va
voir un effet rebond non consommation
sobriété on prend moins l'avion ce qui
nous permet de fermer des lignes
aériennes ce qui permet encore une fois
de moins prendre l'avion et ce qui nous
permet de faire évoluer notre économie
vers une taille plus petite bio
physiquement mais qui pourrait être plus
à même de satisfaire des besoins mais
alors vous vous assumez vous de vouloir
remettre en cause le système capitaliste
c'est une forme de révolution que vous
proposez c'est ce qui expliquait Hélène
Bonduelle dans le portrait qu'elle vous
a consacré mais quelle forme
d'organisation économique est-ce que
vous proposez pour remplacer ce système
capitaliste c'est ça le problème le
capitalisme c'est un système dont
l'objectif principal est déjà
l'accumulation du capital donc la
croissance économique est une forme donc
c'est un système où on a un logiciel
économique qui est concentré sur la
maximisation d'indicateurs financiers
donc le PIB pour les gouvernements les
profits pour les entreprises et les
revenus pour les individus ce logiciel
il peut faire énormément de choses la
seule chose qui ne peut pas faire c'est
produire moins c'est normal on voit bien
une entreprise si elle veut faire des
produits elle ne peut pas produire moins
donc là en fait il faut modifier les
grandes institutions de notre économie
pour pouvoir lui ajouter une nouvelle
fonction que cette fonction de quand on
est dans une situation de stress
écologique d'avoir l'agilité de pouvoir
abattir l'intention la crise de l'eau on
produit un petit peu moins peut-être
progrès technologique
dans un modèle décroissant est-ce que
des entreprises comme Google LVMH ou
totale existerait encore est-ce qu'elles
auraient encore un sens à exister et ben
dans un modèle et que deviendrait leur
salarié accessoirement et poste
croissant déjà il n'y aurait plus
d'entreprises à but lucratif
c'est-à-dire que des coopératives que
des coopératives le créativité limitée
ou habitons lucratif comme il en existe
déjà beaucoup dans l'économie sociale et
solidaire Google se transforme en
coopérative comme ça en claquant des
doigts c'est patagonale à la fin
d'autres entreprises pourraient le faire
aussi ça change rien en fait entre les
mains de son fondateur Google est entre
les mains des actionnaires il y a une
véritable question sur la propriété en
fait des entreprises aujourd'hui on a
une forme de planification plutôt
pratique de l'économie donc c'est une
propriété actionnariale extrêmement
concentrée et surtout la relation que
les actionnaires ont avec une entreprise
est une relation principalement
financière c'est à dire que moi je mets
mon argent chez Google et j'attends un
retour positif sur investissement si je
n'ai pas ce retour objectifs sur
investissement ou si les pas assez grand
je vais mettre mon argent ailleurs en
fait ce logiciel de maximisation il fera
toujours obstacle à la transition
écologique parce que toutes les choses
dont on doit investir aujourd'hui c'est
des choses qui ne vont pas rapporter
l'argent est-ce que cette bascule elle
peut se faire démocratiquement est-ce
qu'on peut mener une révolution pareil
sans aucune forme de violence politique
économique sociale je pense que oui
aujourd'hui justement la démocratie ça
va être le seul système qui nous permet
de réencastrer l'économie sur cette
finalité qu'à celle du bien-être parce
que personne ne sait vraiment quels sont
les besoins comment j'allais vous poser
c'est ma question suivante comment
définit le bien-être sur quels critères
qui définit ça aujourd'hui on a un
système ou une minorité donc possédante
on l'a vu qui prend des décisions dans
ces grandes entreprises qui donc
prennent des décisions sur quel sera le
bien-être et les choses que l'on devrait
produire pour l'intégralité de la
population française et même au-delà
c'est un système qui marche pas très
très bien
si justement on venait démocratiser
cette prise de décision avec par exemple
des conseils multi-parties prenantes
comme on voit dans certaines
coopératives voilà déjà on peut se poser
la question de quoi avons-nous besoin on
a des représentants des usagers on a des
représentants de la municipalité on a
des représentants des travailleurs et on
peut avoir une discussion beaucoup plus
informée sur cette question d'écologie
politique de quoi avons-nous vraiment
besoin et surtout il faut que cette
discussion elle soit basée sur des
besoins concrets et pas à chaque fois
avec une barrière qui est celle de la
lucrativité de dire oui ça on en a
besoin ça écologiquement faudrait le
faire mais on va pas le faire parce que
ça on va pas nous rapporter l'argent
alors si on renonce à la lucrativité
comment est-ce qu'on finance par exemple
un système de protection sociale
équivalent à celui qu'on a aujourd'hui
en France et déjà il faut comprendre que
la croissance économique c'est une
augmentation de la taille du PIB le PIB
lui-même déjà est un indicateur de flux
donc quand on parle de la croissance ne
finance pas le système social c'est
l'activité économique qui finance le
système social et sa croissance permet
de financer l'augmentation des coûts de
certains services
et là quand on se pose cette question on
se dit mais aujourd'hui le problème du
dépassement écologique c'est que ça va
venir exacerber certains des coups par
exemple les coûts de santé liés à la
pollution de l'air donc aujourd'hui
c'est un petit peu une pyramide de Ponzi
de se dire il faut essayer de produire
de plus en plus de 4x4 par exemple et on
va récupérer un petit peu d'argent avec
la TVA sur ces 4x4 pour ensuite payer
les soins des personnes touchées par la
pollution de l'air sachant
qu'aujourd'hui déjà et bah les recettes
liées aux activités polluantes ne sont
pas suffisantes pour payer l'intégralité
des coûts donc la décroissance est un
petit peu une approche pas la prévention
de se dire est-ce qu'on pourrait pas à
la source justement simplifier les
besoins réorganiser ces entreprises pour
éviter de créer le problème qu'il faudra
ensuite résoudre merci beaucoup Timothée
Paris qu'on a pas eu le temps d'aller au
bout de votre raisonnement jusqu'à
l'étape de la Poste croissance mais ça
ce sera pour ceux qui achètent en votre
livre ralentir ou périr l'économie de la
décroissance du rappel son titre 30 000
exemplaires écoulés vous restez avec
nous parce que nous accueillons à
présent nos affranchis
allez installez-vous nous accueillons
donc Mariette Darry grand Nathan Dewaere
et Marco pommier on va commencer par
vous Marco bonsoir chronique Bourbon
Express consacré un rapport
parlementaire aujourd'hui exactement ce
soir je vous raconte l'histoire de
l'arroseur à rosée alors qu'est-ce que
c'est que cette histoire et ben en fait
dans un rapport parlementaire qui a
fuité dans la presse le rassemblement
national est accusé d'être une courroie
de transmission efficace du discours
russe c'est l'une des conclusions
embarrassante de la commission
d'enquêtes sur les ingérences étrangères
ironie de l'histoire c'est pourtant à
l'initiative du groupe de Marine Le Pen
que cette commission avait été créée
c'est même Jean-Philippe Tanguy député
du rassemblement national qui présidait
cet instant alors hier qu'est-ce qu'il a
fait Jean-Philippe Tanguy et ben il a
convoqué une conférence de presse
opération des minages écoutez
je suis vraiment consterné je pense que
c'est le mot aucun élément à charge
nouveau cela sont évoqués en permanence
les mêmes revues de presse les mêmes
rumeurs les mêmes allégations mais qui
sont toutes démenties par les auditions
que nous avons fait des services de
renseignement des institutions des
auditions sous serment des personnalités
du rassemblement national nous étions
accusés de vouloir faire cette
commission d'enquête un instrument
politique c'est bien Renaissance qui a
fait de cette commission d'enquête un
instrument politique pour essayer
évènement de nous discréditer voilà
amertume de Jean-Philippe Tanguy et
pourtant Clément le rassemblement
national comptait beaucoup sur cette
commission pour laver l'honneur du parti
pour couper court aux soupçons de
collusion avec la Russie c'est raté le
rapport a été adopté on se voit pour 5
contre colère de Marine Le Pen hier à la
qualifié le rapport de sectaires et de
malhonnête elle dénonce un procès
politique et le rassemblement national
cible une députée en particulier
constance le grip la rapporteuse de
cette commission oui en fait le grip
elle était aux côtés de Jean-Philippe
Tanguy pendant les auditions de cette
commission en tant que rapporteuse c'est
elle qui a rédigé le rapport
parlementaire et dans ce rapport
justement et ben elle parle du
rassemblement national comme un
véritable relais des positions russes
elle souligne des invitations fréquentes
de membres du RN en Russie la députée
Renaissance insiste aussi sur
l'alignement du parti sur le discours du
Kremlin au moment de l'annexion illégale
de la Crimée je cite c'était en 2014
alors coïncidence ou pas cette année-là
Marine Le Pen contracté un prêt auprès
d'une banque tchéco russe face au refus
des banques françaises conscience ce
grip qui se défend de toute partialité
vis-à-vis du RL
je laisse le président la commission
d'enquête faire l'analyse qu'il entend
faire de ce rapport nous avons fait nous
les parlementaires de la majorité et les
parlementaires d'autres groupes
politiques ont été s'investir beaucoup
dans ce travail un travail sérieux
documenté honnête est-ce que le
rassemblement national a des regrets sur
ce rapport officiellement non même si on
coulisse on avoue que le bilan de cette
commission est loin d'être parfait on
reconnaît même une forme de naïveté
vis-à-vis de la majorité on ne
s'attendait pas à autant de malhonnêteté
ils veulent juste nous salir me disait
un député RN ce matin vous l'avez
compris Clément le torchon brûle entre
Renaissance et le rassemblement national
et c'est peut-être pas terminé ce
rapport de 213 pages il doit être publié
officiellement jeudi prochain merci
beaucoup Marco pommier Timothée que je
peux vous interroger sur ce rapport
parlementaire vous en faites pas mais
vous jetez un œil quand même au débat de
l'Assemblée qu'elle regarde vous portez
économiste sur ce qui se passe dans
l'hémicycle bon déjà je vais pas pouvoir
commenter moi ça fait 10 ans que je suis
en Suède donc vous êtes loin des
connectés de la vie politique française
et en plus en tant que universitaire
vraiment qui fait de la macroéconomie
théorique donc une double déconnexion
avec la réalité politique du moment mais
je rattrape mon retard bon je vais
revenir vers vous vous en faites pas
vous passez à vous n'attendez bonsoir
alors pour joignez donc l'équipe des
affranchis bienvenue merci ici sur le
plateau de savon regarde et donc vous
êtes écrivain et ce soir vous avez tenu
à féliciter la revue le grand continent
oui le grand continent qui est une revue
très originale parce qu'elle repose sur
deux parties pris premièrement essayez
de ramener les problèmes géopolitiques
et politiques à leur échelle pertinente
c'est-à-dire l'échelle d'un monde
mondialisé et l'échelle s'agissant de la
France d'une France européanisée en
quelque sorte et deuxièmement essayez
d'avoir un débat du style structurant et
non pas structuré c'est-à-dire non pas
de reprendre des concepts galvaudés
flous mais d'imposer des nouveaux
concepts et des nouvelles questions et
c'est dans ce contexte qui publie leur
deuxième numéro de leur revue papier aux
éditions Gallimard fracture de la guerre
étendue de l'Ukraine au metavère et
alors comment est-ce qu'ils abordent la
thématique de la guerre alors le point
de départ en effet c'est la guerre en
Ukraine et la question de savoir comment
cette guerre va avoir un impact profond
sur l'avenir et va redéfinir en fait
l'avenir de l'Europe et puis surtout
comment nommer ce qui est en train de se
passer alors face à cela la grande
hypothèse consisterait à dire que nous
assistons à un retour de la guerre
froide ou voir à un choc des
civilisations et ce sont des hypothèses
qui sont entre guillemets accrédité par
le discours du Kremlin discours
consistant à avoir la nostalgie de
l'URSS à parler d'un Occident décadent
etc mais le parti pris de ce de cette
revue donc c'est de refuser de voir les
choses ainsi l'histoire ne se répète pas
ni en tragédie ni en farce écrivent
Gilles graissagny et Matteo Malik dans
leur article introductif et beaucoup
d'articles notamment de Jean-Marie
guéheno réfléchissent sur le fait qu'il
y ait un paradoxe presque dans la
difficulté à nommer ce qui se passe
c'est à dire que du côté russe on a une
volonté de dépolitiser les sociétés en
interdisant de dire qu'il s'agit d'une
guerre on parle d'opération spéciale
mais en disant que l'Occident mène une
guerre économique contre la Russie donc
si vous voulez on parle de guerre à
l'envers du côté européen disent les
auteurs on a une réaction dans les
sociétés civiles qui est essentiellement
d'ordre empathique qui passe passant par
des images qui nous terrifient qui nous
éveuguent sur les réseaux sociaux qu'il
compare un petit peu aux
applaudissements qu'il y avait vis-à-vis
des soignants pendant la crise sanitaire
c'est-à-dire que les Européens disent
que l'Ukraine est en guerre mais le
grand tabou de la parole européenne
c'est de dire que nous aussi nous sommes
en guerre pour des raisons évidentes ce
tabou donc de partout sauf en Ukraine il
y a une si vous voulez une facilité une
évidence à employer le mot guerre et ça
selon les auteurs de ce numéro c'est une
des très grandes différences avec la
guerre froide ou du côté des sociétés
civiles par exemple pendant le blocus de
Berlin c'était pas seulement une émotion
une empathie un choc mais c'était
vraiment une réaction de politisation
directe et d'inquiétude personnelle
entre guillemets des pays impliqués
alors si c'est pas un retour de la
guerre froide qu'est-ce que c'est alors
leur grille de lecture c'est le concept
de ce qu'ils appellent l'intérêt c'est à
dire la fin d'un monde tel que nous
l'avons connu structuré autour de
certains rêves qu'il s'agisse de la
nation de la mondialisation modernisée
de la croissance peut-être le monde
libre le concept de monde libre le prima
des États-Unis et le fait que nous
allons vers un monde totalement inconnu
on sait pas trop à quoi il va ressembler
et entre les deux peuvent naître des
monstres ou des événements absolument
entre guillemets apocalyptiques et dans
cette perspective le numéro du grand
continent contient le texte d'une
conférence très intéressante donnée par
Bruno Latour en 2022 donc peu avant sa
mort conférence où il propose une
analyse comparative de ce qu'il nomme
vraiment deux conflits au même titre des
conflits dans la guerre en Ukraine
naturellement et le conflit climatique
le fait qu'il y a des territoires où les
conditions de vie deviennent de plus en
plus impossibles et dans ce contexte là
il propose de relire vous savez le
fameux texte d'Ernest Renan qu'est ce
qu'une nation qui était prononcé dans un
temps de crise aussi la crise alsacienne
et où Renan disait que ce qui définit
une nation ce n'est pas la langue ce
n'est pas entre guillemets ce n'est pas
les origines donc ce n'est pas
l'architecture ce n'est pas le style etc
mais c'est le plébiscite de tous les
jours autrement dit ce n'est pas le seul
le territoire mais c'est l'âme d'une
nation et face et donc évidemment le
rejet du sol pour pour Renan c'était le
rejet de la détermination
identitaire or ce que dit la tour et qui
est très intéressante c'est que oui il
faut rejeter un concept purement
géographique purement identitaire du sol
mais que on peut aujourd'hui définir les
nations françaises ou nation européenne
à travers un concept écologique du sol
c'est à dire le sol en tant que le sol
habitait le sol abîmé le sol périssable
le sol qui contient des ressources et
qui présente les conditions de vie ce
sol là ce sol écologique c'est
évidemment celui qui est je dirais vécu
pendant la crise climatique mais aussi
pendant la guerre en Ukraine avec la
question du gaz et du Pétrole très bien
merci beaucoup Nathan de verre on passe
à vous Mariette darrigran vous avez
retenu cette semaine un mot qui était un
peu au centre de du plomb du ministre
délégué au compte public Gabriel Attal
c'est le mot fraude
parce que ce mot a suscité un débat
comme si on voulait refaire le vieux
match politique classique le thème de
gauche serait plutôt la lutte contre la
fraude fiscale alors que le thème de
droite serait censé être la lutte contre
la faute sociale mais quand on regarde
dans le détail j'ai eu beaucoup de
choses sur les effets et non pas le mot
mais la chose et c'est complètement
trans partisan trans classe sociale etc
mettons je vais prendre un exemple un
patron qui ne déclare pas tous ces
salariés et une famille qui déclare pas
tous ses morts et ben on peut avoir un
pic de centenaire en Algérie par exemple
et une baisse des cotisations sociales
dans une région de France c'est très
différent c'est pas dans le même endroit
de la société mais c'est exactement la
même chose de mon point de vue
c'est-à-dire un désir de déjouer l'État
pour pour piquer de l'argent finalement
c'est ça même chose avec les APL avec
les médecins complaisants en termes
d'arrêt maladie si vous voulez donc tout
ça c'est beaucoup de choses beaucoup de
manifestations d'une seule fraude tout
ça c'est un peu pareil au fond c'est ça
l'idée
tout ça ce mot est ancien il est
médiéval la fraude on n'a pas inventé
21e siècle puis il est je dirais qu'il
est presque innocent des facto
définitivement quelqu'un qui dans le
métro saute sur la au-dessus de la
barrière et ouais elles sont payées ou
quelqu'un qui détourne des millions nous
n'avons qu'un mot pour dire tout ça
c'est fraudeur et puis c'est vaguement
sympathique aux États-Unis vous dites
food tout de suite la prison est en vue
je voulais dire qu'il y a une forme de
complaisance en France autour de ce mot
national il y a vraiment quelque chose
qui se fait et qui est étayé sur nos
mythologies au sens littéraire du terme
si je prends le Roman de Renard c'est
quand même un héros formidable du
Moyen-Âge la le vocabulaire est produite
parce que les prolixe parce que c'est
des fraudes fraudulateurs il y a plein
de mots ensuite bien sûr nous avons le
chevalier mandrin après on a Arsène
Lupin donc on a si vous voulez une
espèce de d'ailleurs je me disais un peu
dans un mauvais esprit voilà la bonne
assimilation quelque sorte les Français
les plus récents et ben ils ont que tout
à fait intégré avec le système beaucoup
plus peut-être que les lumières de
Voltaire ou le la raison cartésienne
voilà donc non pour finir je voudrais
quand même pointer quelque chose qui est
plus embêtant c'est que cette fraude et
médiévale elle est ancienne elle est
archaïque nous sommes en risque de
régresser à ce moment où il y a pas
encore d'État aujourd'hui donc ma
question franchement je me suis posé
cette question en regardant tous les
effets de ce mot et bien est-ce que nous
sommes vraiment dans notre doux pays
avec un état assez moderne pour fixer de
manière extrêmement claire la frontière
entre le lysite et l'illicit merci
beaucoup Maria Darrieux rend Timothée
que vous avez suivi le débat sur la
fraude sociale et là dans ma tête
j'avais plein d'idées qui faisaient et
moi bien sûr je pense à ce concept de
fraude écologique qui n'existe pas mais
qui pourrait exister mais tout à fait
le greenwashing est même avant de parler
de fraude de se dire que Macron
économiquement aujourd'hui
quand nous ne respectons pas les limites
planétaires c'est à dire quand nous
dépassons ouvertement et légalement la
biocapacité des écosystèmes ce qui va
venir faire pression et peut-être les
dégradés à terme nous sommes en fraude
vis-à-vis d'une nature que nous ne
respectons pas et donc là aussi il va
falloir commencer à considérer la nature
comme un service avec lequel on ne peut
qu'interagir et pour cela il y a des
pistes évidemment très riches dans votre
livre je rappelle le titre ralentir ou
périr merci beaucoup Timothée Paris et
merci à vous nos affranchis de Ça vous
regarde chers téléspectateurs on vous
souhaite évidemment une bonne soirée un
bon week-end et rendez-vous mardi avec
Myriam
[Musique]